hey what is up guys I'm Kip EHD here and
today Apple unveiled what they're
calling the iPad pro basically it's a
huge iPad like an oversized like like
really this is an absolutely massive
tablet I've played with the Microsoft
Surface all the way up to the Samsung
Galaxy Note pro but this one takes the
cake
biggest traditional chaplet out there
right now so with it being bigger you
get a couple of things with that one a
much bigger brighter more impressive
display this is a twelve point nine inch
display diagonally with a resolution of
2732 by 2048
so more than quad HD this thing is
packin more pixels on the 13-inch retina
MacBook Pro and it is beautiful pretty
much everything you look at on this
display looks great and with that big
old body you have space for more
speakers so Apple put a speaker on all
four corners of the tablet they're still
not front-facing or anything but this
does a better job with stereo audio and
creating a bigger more impressive
soundstage especially for movies and
then of course with all that space you
get you also have a bigger battery so
we're looking at a 10 hour battery life
according to Apple and since it is a new
top-of-the-line
iPad we also get their highest end specs
again I don't know how much RAM is in
this tablet I hope it's more than 2
gigabytes at this point but the chip on
board is an absolute beast the Apple a9
x is their new 64-bit chip for the
tablet and besides being all quoted as
you know 2 times faster and processing
and graphics I'm sure it will probably
benchmark off the damn charts they
showed it editing 3 streams of full 4k
video and handling it like super smooth
and all the multitasking goodies in iOS
9 seemed to work great especially on
this big display now the other thing
that's turning heads with this iPad pro
as I'm sure you've seen already is the
new first-party accessories first of all
the iPad pro is the first and only Apple
product with this new little connector
over here on the side called the smart
connector Apple is kicking off smart
connector accessories with this smart
keyboard that folds from a case may be
reminiscent of a certain other keyboard
fold out case by a certain other
manufacturer a Microsoft Surface pro uh
but yeah it's using the same key style
as the new macbook so shorter key throws
no built-in
play no battery in this guy but it's
pretty thin enlighten it automatically
pairs with the iPad when you snap it
into the smart connector simple enough
Apple will sell it for 169 then there's
the Apple pencil who wants a stylus you
have to get them and put them away and
you'll lose him yuck
nobody wants a stylus so let's not use a
stylus well so much for that Apple is
now going to sell this $99 stylus
alongside the iPad pro and it's a weird
one at that now it seems to work really
well with the iPad pro which is built
for the demos showed that it's
pressure-sensitive and tilt sensitive so
you can write with the point down or
shade stuff in with the points sideways
and get inviting levels of depth and
darkness based on how hard you press and
it automatically pairs with the iPad but
you also have to remember the pencil has
its own battery so you kind of have to
worry about that sometimes and it
charges via a male lightning connector
so the suggested way to charge it is by
plugging it into the iPad pro which if
you ask me looks like a really easy way
to break it either way at the end of the
day this tablet as beautiful and amazing
as it is I'm having a hard time coming
up with a target audience for the device
like is it a student who wants to
replace our laptop with an iPad well no
not really it's an $800 tablet not
really in the budget is it a creative
person's tablet or a businessman I don't
know basically what I can tell you is
it's just a beast for media consumption
reading news watching videos playing
games anything that involves consuming
media of any kind is enhanced with this
iPad pro as you would expect from the
bigger size it is a bit heavy to hold
with 1.57 pounds it's a little bit
expensive starting at 800 bucks and you
have to get the thousand dollar 128 gig
version to get LTE so I'm not sure the
pro in the name really means anything
it's just a bigger iPad and for people
that already love the idea of a big
portable display this one's even bigger
please don't take pictures with this
anyway we'll see how it pans out in the
full review let me know your thoughts
and also don't forget to check out my
iPhone 6s impressions video also from
earlier today Apple did announce two
things today so that's link to right
below that like button
thanks for watching this one guys and
I'll talk to you in the next one peace